B
I hope everyone enjoyed lunch um I'm
delighted uh to introduce Edith Cohen
who's going to give our four fourth Talk
of the day and the talk is going to be
on robustness to add to Adaptive inputs
a case study with count
sketch thank you so this is a joint work
with a bunch of
people um I'll also cover a lot of
background that I think H already
covered and touch already covered in
this but
uh um so it's about the robustness to
Adaptive
inputs um okay so what are adaptive
inputs so basically we have a any
randomized
algorithm ER it's initialized with some
internal Randomness raw and and that's
not visible from the outside kind of and
in the nonadaptive setting there is a
sequence of queries and a sequence of
answers and the assumptions here is that
the next queries don't depend
um on
the on the prior answers right so um so
this is a so then so that and in the
Adaptive setting though there could be a
dependence sorry it goes by itself I
don't know right okay so this
arises when there is like a system with
feedback or in an adversarial setting
where the goal is to construct
bad
input so that's how this kind of
settings with dependence
arise um so the Adaptive setting is kind
of more fragile to
analyze H so usually with a randomized
algorithm ER we construct it so that for
any possible input uh the probability
that the answer is correct is a of over
the choices of the internal Randomness
is at least one minus Delta for some
very small Delta meaning for any input
almost all choices of internal
Randomness
work and then if we have our inputs it's
just like a union bound so this means
that if we want to find a bad input we
have to have a many many many trials
until we one over Delta kind of
Trials H until we find the something
that the randomness is bad
for um in the Adaptive setting it's
trickier because the output leak
information on the internal
Randomness
and um and in that
case um and and this analysis kind of
breaks down because H the answer the
answers depend on the randomness and
then the queries next queries depend on
the randomness so
um so we can't apply the same
analysis and as a result potentially by
asking a qu a particular queries we can
very quickly zoom on an input that has
an incorrect
output um so today I'll kind of h i I'll
review kind of techniques for uper
bounds to make a a algorithms robust and
I think it's some overlap with what K
talked about and what tul also
mentioned and and then I'll give some
examples where if we get in to the
sketch with with count sketch and kind
of a redesign the sketch a little bit H
we can get some improvements over
that and then I'll also talk about
attacks a basically a method to
construct an input that is kind of
adversarial for the randomness how
susceptible are the sketches that we
usually know and love to are to
this um is really this adaptive input is
it really an issue in
practice
um okay so H I'll start with a kind of
background where this techniques that we
use uh for for robustifying algorithms
come from
um so uh okay so
for the setting is like statistical
queries over
samples H we have a some distribution
over some
space and and and then we take a
sample and the inputs are just like
predicates and the outputs that we want
are estimates of the expectation of the
predicate
um and uh what we do usually in this
setting is just look at the empirical
average the average of the predicate
over our sample and and usually in the
nonadaptive setting it generalizes very
well and we can even support if we have
a sample of size d we can expect to
support kind of a exponential in D
number of queries and answer them all
correctly um this is just Hing
bound um the probability that the
empirical average deviates by more
than with d that is kind of one over
Alpha Square log one over Delta
um the probability that we deviate by
more than Alpha from the the empirical
average deviates by more than Alpha from
um the expectation over the distribution
is at most
Delta and then it's a un bound with our
queries um but in this setting it's not
easy it's not hard to even quickly come
up with an
example um that if we can kind of issue
queries adaptively we can kind of ask
which questions on like the bit
representation of actually the items
that are selected in the samples and
kind of uncover enough on the sample and
overfit the sample and we can do it just
with the order D
queries um so if we have the exact
empirical average as a
response and then ER there were
beautiful work by two groups of
people
um um yeah so um and then they kind of
showed they connected this with
differential privacy
um and uh they show
that ER we can get
better than that
um um so if so each time if our predic
so if our predicates are not dependent
on the sample we can answer
exponentially many queries if our
predicates are dependent in the sample
but we do empirical average is linear
but here if the predicate depends on the
sample but kind of preses The Preserves
the privacy of the sample preserve the
meaning that we can't tell if a
particular element is sample or not it's
a and the and the Privacy parameter kind
of should match
our accuracy and and these are just
Epsilon Delta DP this with these
parameters then as long as the
predicates that we generate can of
preserve this
RDP the empirical
average will still
generalize so the meaning that the
predicates cannot ve the the um the
empirical average will not be too far
off from the distribution
okay um so for that to happen of course
we cannot report the ER the empirical
each time yeah um so um so we
basically so basically we want to like
suppose we want kind of accuracy that is
fixed like
0.1 um so we we need the our algorithm
after our queries to be Epsilon order
one kind of
DP and then our sums the sums have kind
of sensitivity one
and uh so we need to add a privacy noise
with a standard deviation that is about
square root of R in order ER using DP
composition ER in order for the overall
privacy ER budget to be overall privacy
cost to be ER to to be this so basically
if this is the amount of noise that we
add we need the number of samples to be
order of that times some constant right
so that means that we can answer a d
square queries using I mean I'm hiding
here all sorts of factors uh using D
samples H so this is statistical
queries and then there is there was a
and there is actually a matching lower
bounds so for in the case for
statistical
queries um this is the tight kind of
you can there is queries that are based
on fingerprinting code by har andman and
um
and and also stank Anan that improved it
that
ER that that kind of reveal the sample
after this Square queries
okay so now the next idea is I think
tacha and K also talked about it it's by
a beautiful work with Kim
Manish
and
and and and now they are turning this
technique to use for randomized
algorithms ER so um so here in so so
basically it's it's kind of almost like
I know a trick and it's basically
something that is a designed for a
samples on statistical queries so now
each each instantiation each instance of
the randomized algorithm uh it's treated
like a sample so these are basically the
internal randomness of the nonadaptive
algorithm or the
sketch and um and basically we just
apply the same mechanism there so
basically we instantiate instead of the
samples we instantiate the copies of
that nonadaptive randomized
algorithm and then each time we have an
input we kind of feed it to all the all
these
copies and then each copy gives us an
answer but we we we're careful with how
we use the
answers ER we we need to do some DP
aggregation ER of these samples and
and and then we we just output
that and uh and then that means that we
can support this Square such queries as
long as it we preserve the
Privacy um so this was very very useful
initially H and Coors introduced this
idea for streaming settings but it's
also useful for dynamic graph algorithms
it was also used in machine un learning
and another nice things about the use of
DP here that ER there is a a whole
Machinery of differential privacy so
answering a sequence of queries that
kind of allows us to control the Privacy
loss so we pay we can pay the Privacy
cost not on all queries just on queries
that say deviate from some prior or
queries
where um just like a the count is over
above something the like if it's like a
statistical query type of thing or the
count is even in a narrow range
we can like it's a between threshold
queries so this is this kind of toolkit
is a very very useful when designing
algorithms because for example in
Dynamic algorithm settings or even in
streaming settings um on most inputs
there would be almost no change in the
output H so you don't pay for this
queries so basically this order d square
queries that you can support is order D
Square D Square queries where kind of
the outputs changed or something happens
the output was kind of far from some
boundary that you incur the Privacy
cost and and this is kind of important
because in the last year there was a
really nice paper by Guy Blanch from
Stanford um
where he kind of showed that you can do
that without DP you basically H Just
Produce this sample of kind of instances
of the algorithm and then for each query
you just can take a subsample and you
can return anything you want so you can
even like choose like one algorithm and
then apply it and return the output and
then this attacks before just won't work
just because it's just the randomness of
your choice so you can still answer a d
square kind of queries if you just
select each
randomly um and it looked um but what
kind of H breaks down for many of the
applications is that this setup doesn't
support techniques like this sparse
Vector that allow you kind of to pay the
Privacy cost pay
only for a fraction of the queries
usually a fraction of the queries is
where there is a
change um so and I don't know if it's
possible to get around that so we'll
stick with this kind of
framework uh
um okay so now let's use this to make a
count sketch robust so we can just apply
this technique out of the box but it's
also but but I I'll show that we if we
think about it a little bit more we can
redesign count sketch to kind of get a
little bit more out of
it um so okay what is a count sketch
that we all know it's a basically a
popular dimensionality reduction
techniques um the randomness Ro is used
to it's
by um yeah it's an old technique by
Moses who was here yesterday not here
today on coal
um
um so uh um so so basically it's like
you take vectors and you produce another
Vector with a much smaller Dimension H
by a matrix of the ve the input vectors
are size and the output vectors are size
d and
uh um and and basically it's you just
take the inner products of a the input
Vector with the other vectors and and
and that's your
sketch um and the the nice thing about
the nice features of count sketch is
that it allows you to recover it it
reserve some good properties of the long
vectors including its L2 heavy
heaters and another really really useful
thing is that inner products of O sorry
what did they
do inner products of two vectors can be
recovered from their
sketches so okay just a reminder what
are L2 heavy
heaters um L2 heavy heaters are
basically entries of the input vectors
say that have at least there is like a
parameter Epsilon that have at least
Epsilon of the L2
Mass H meaning the entry square is at
least Epsilon of the L2 Norm square and
this is kind of a refined definition
that is kind of more convenient in many
settings um so uh H so basically you
only need to be to dominate kind of
Epsilon fraction of the tail so you
think about it is that some keys some
entries are like heavy eers you put them
ER and and like for Epsilon like one
over Epsilon of the heaviest ENT entries
are like can be Heavy Hitters and then
they just need to kind of dominate The
Tail which is er the rest with the um
heavy entries removed H so this is the
L2 Heavy
Hitters um so okay so this is what count
sketch looks
like um so this is the number of linear
measurements and the and there is a
parameter that depends on your Epsilon
it's about one over Epsilon it's kind of
the width of the sketch and basically
the format is that we have a kind of the
D measurements are part are divided to
like sets
of B measurement vectors
each
and um okay and each set is specified by
two random hash
functions ER
one one is a h that kind of is it just
partitions it partitions all the entries
of the big
Vector ER into a b kind of buckets and
randomly so that each bucket gets about
one over B of all the entries and then
there is another hash function that kind
of assigns a random sign and and this
can be also presented in the form of a
vector such as the inner V so okay and
and then what each bucket gets is that
all the entries that map to it there
some multiplied by the random sign okay
so this can be presented as an inner
product so what does this gives us in
terms of Heavy
Hitters um so H for each uh key suppose
we want to know if it's a heavy
heater we
look okay so for each key here we look
at the bucket it Maps
into ER the value it will contribute to
it is its value multiplied by the sign
and then there would be one over B of
the other entries let's say no other
heavy heat or map to it they will
contribute to it with essentially a
random sign so basically the
expectation of that bucket is multiplied
by the sign is basically the value of
the key and the variance basically
depends on the L2 Norm of the
tail so what happens is that if the key
is heavy enough this will be much larger
than this and then that
the bucket will be very close to the to
the value of the heavy heitter if it's
heavy enough so this is the so basically
you you you have a multiple sets
logarithmic number of sets sets set sets
sorry
um that are basically the Value Plus
Some
Noise ER and basically that's also the
information that the sketch provides no
matter what estimator you
apply the original paper use the median
estimator
um and uh
okay um taking the media the median of
this measurement so basically you can
run over I mean there are much more
efficient ways to do it but you can run
over all the keys and then look at all
the buckets in each set look at the
buckets that this key falls into and
then h Tes the M multiply that value by
the
sign that's how you do the recovery and
then you get number of from each set you
get one estimate for the value of each
key you take the med the
median um okay so this is how it works
okay so now we want to apply it h to
apply this robustness wrapper with a
count
sketch um so the usually way is the
straightforward
way um we basically take a um we we take
we create basically we take this whole
sketch like logarithmic number of sets
of H
measurements and uh
we
um and we we basically replicate it
multiple times H and
then we ask how many queries we can
answer H so basically for each query
which is an input Vector we need to run
over H all the keys but because of the
spse vector like techniques we only pay
privacy cost for the keys that are
actually Heavy Hitters which there can
be at most b b is like that number of
buckets one over Epsilon of them so
basically it's like for our inputs we
basically need to issue our time B quer
is to the sketch so we lose a little bit
here so basically we need square root of
that with the robustness wrapper IID
sketches of that size and then if we
plug it all
in with a sketch of size
d h we can answer
a um d s Epsilon cubed h different in we
can process that many different inputs
so that Cube kind of seems out of place
we wanted to get rid of
it um
so okay so one
Improvement ER one is basically to just
reduce the Privacy units instead of
charge the whole sketch Log sets
logarithmic number of sets of ER for
every input we just H reduce it but that
doesn't H that doesn't give us that much
it doesn't improve this
Factor um the idea that we used in the
end is to reduce the Privacy unit just
to like a single bucket in the
sketch um because every input kind of we
we answer um many queries for many
keys um so and and the the way the
privacy analysis goes we kind of
charge for each size query on every
single key we kind of charge the full
sketch the full set for every query and
then we can get less out of it in terms
of the Privacy
accounting
um so uh H so the idea is to kind of H
just like charge like a single
bucket um but the issue is that we can't
fit it into that same framework because
these buckets are not independent they
are dependent they are based the buckets
in each set based on random partition of
all the keys and and the buckets in a
random partition kind of are not
independent they are not the randomness
is not drawn independently from the same
distribution
um
so uh so we kind of needed to redesign
the
sketch
um but if we I mean we can see and but
that allows us to kind of reduce that
Cube to a square which is kind of the
optimal um so er so we needed to do
several redesigns um so we also ER kind
of we we need to needed to kind of tweak
the Privacy analysis
so
that um so each bucket is
only carefully charged to the queries of
keys that kind of map to that
bucket
um so and and then we kind of needed a
different estimator we used that kind of
has the predicate form so to identify
the heavy heers rather than medians we
kind of looked at the number of bucket
that the
um that their sign aligned with the sign
of the random
Keys ER but so basically now that
modified count sketch kind of looked
like that so basically instead of the
hash function that kind of
partitions H to B buckets
basically every linear measurement is
basically every key
maps in with probability that is one
over
B and then and then it's one or minus
one with equal probabilities in this
case so this is kind of a slightly
modified count sketch it's basically the
same distribution at each count sketch
bucket and it's the performance of
estimators is very much the same and we
can also do a kind of analysis with
limited
Independence um but
maybe it loses just a little bit because
it's not a perfect partition because
then instead of getting one estimate
from each set we just get kind of a a
random number kind of
estimates um for each
kid um so now we did all that work kind
of a just to be able to H apply that
framework that kind of works with IID
samples and I don't know if this
redesign was necessary it kind of really
feels that a count sketch as is um the
with the buckets we should be able to
somehow get the same um do the same with
but um I I still don't know how I mean
it's basically that hammer that
differential privacy uh
hammer kind of is designed for a
IID um pieces of Randomness that are
kind of
IID
um so okay so now I want to talk about
the other end of things which is attacks
so with statistical queries over
sample this were like
tight in an nonadaptive case we could
answer exponentially many queries in the
sample
size um so uh um so with the exact
estimator we could answer only or D
queries and that was
tight and with the DP we can we could
instead of D could get d square and that
was tight but with randomized algorithms
with the rapper we get this kind of
upper bounds but we don't have the mat
we don't have lower
bounds um and you know we can look at
any particular sketching structure or
algorithm and then May maybe the
estimator that it comes it comes with
it's already robust right maybe it's
much better than this and U and maybe
this this square is also we can get I
mean even if that doesn't work maybe we
can get better than this D Square um and
and our initial feelings when we worked
on that that was with tamash telani and
URI and couple two students Moshe and
shin our initial feeling was that you
know we should be able to do something
better with count sketch
um but yeah but it apparently not um so
okay so now
generally for attacking linear sketches
the attack goal is to produce an input
with a sketch that is kind of out of
distribution
and then we look at the number of
queries we need to issue and the number
of rounds of
adaptivity um so this is just
a okay so um the attacks okay so
uh
um okay so this is a so now we're
thinking we're looking at not just count
sketch and Heavy
Hitters um
ER any form of dimensionality reduction
via linear
map um
and and the count sketch the AMS sketch
JL transform are kind of examples to
that also kind of compression layers in
Trend layers in neural networks are kind
of example of that and then basically
the goal is to of the attack is kind of
to construct bad inputs
and in the literature there are kind of
two types of attacks on such linear
sketches ER so um or linear Maps let's
say h the first is kind of so basically
you have a kind of inputs of size n and
there is some linear map and you have
get something of size d and it and uh
you want to
um okay so H so one thing you can do to
attack is basically to add a lot of
noise to your vector such that it's not
no longer
recognizable but you can still ER
recover
it um so this is a so basically
a H so basically H the noise that you
add can have a huge GM but then it kind
of falls in the null
space
um so a theory work on that but was on
linear sketches was by Hart and WRA in
2013 and then there was this work in
2020 that they actually tried it on on
amist and basically you take these
numbers and you add a huge amount of
random noise a huge gnome and then the
the kind of neural network and still
recovers the number so we can see the
number but the number is the we can see
it now but kind of the noise is
invisible to the sketch H the other type
is basically add a tiny little amount of
noise to the input Vector H but that
will
completely get the sketch out of
distribution um so
uh um so there there have been some work
on that for the AMS sketches and also in
for constructing adversarial inputs for
niron networks uh so basically we just
want to quickly in this attacks the goal
is to quickly Z zoom in on a small noise
that kind of completely throws away the
sketch and
the and the question is how hard it is
to do and it seems
like I mean we we have we we explore
this with all sorts of linear sketches
but it seems like that this square is
kind of
inherent
um okay sorry quick question on the
first one in the I uh on the first
attack on the previous page what is the
downside of this it sounds like a noise
which is the best possible thing you
could hope for it's in the no space of
your sketch is not actually altering
anything how's this what's the attack so
the attack okay so I called it an attack
but basically it's just a kind of a way
to mess it up it's like you can't see
the input but then
the yeah so I don't know you can think
of it as an attack it's kind of a it's
an attack in the sense that if you were
to observe the adversarial input you
can't answer it but the algorithm can
still answer it anywh
um yes so like you don't know what it
yeah like something like that it
basically confuses the the sketch right
like you can't the human this time the
human can't tell and it doesn't confuse
the sketch sorry it confuses the human
the human can't tell what it is but the
sketch still recovers it um
so uh I mean I yeah and and here it's
like you just add a little bit of noise
that the second thing
that that actually confuses the sketch
so it's kind of two types of ways to
mess up to mess up with this linear
sketches I maybe I shouldn't have used
ATT attack right but gotta thanks
yeah
um um
okay okay so
now
okay so okay so uh for count sketch
so our first question was whether the
classic estimator was kind of already
robust um so I I'll just review that so
we basically constructed an attack that
is kind of linear in the size of the
sketch which nearly matches the kind of
trivial upper bound of using a fresh
part of the sketch a fresh subset of
rows for each
query ER that was against our initial
intuition we thought that because of
median and this and that it will be a
little bit more
robust and interestingly the attack had
a very small constant and it actually
barely was barely adaptive you just all
the queries that you
issued ER were kind of together and the
only adversarial input in the end it
that was the only one that depended on
all the queries and it was also a fairly
efficient so basically count
sketch um so basically you you kind of
look at the noise added to each
bucket um so basically this is not the
number of queries we needed in order to
kind of bias the to create a new Vector
for which the noise part the the bias of
the buckets is kind of exceeds by
ER factor of
R
the um the the bias that that that we
would expect so I mean the noise that we
would expect meaning it can obscure
heavy heaters that are factor of R
largers because the noise would be kind
of factor of R
larger um so this is like and and it's a
pretty natural attack it's just
basically take a vector with some Heavy
Hitters and you just add random noise in
different places and you just combine
this r i mean
we'll okay I'll I'll talk about the
general
attack um so um okay so now the question
is can we do better than this quadratic
robust
estimator H and then we we could show
The Following that basically any Cor
heavy heater estimator for count sketch
can be attacked with quadratic number of
inputs so the median the the simple
median estimator can be attacked with a
um number of input that is linear in the
size of the sketch but any correct
estimator can be attacked um with the
number of queries that is quadratic of
in the number of the sketch and it's
still the like this weakest adap
setting um
that um that basically the queries are
completely independent and issued
together and the only thing in the end
is the ER is the adversarial
input um and also the attacked vectors
are very natural it's like again one
heavy
heiter and the and the rest are and and
random noise
and it also can be implemented in a
streaming
setting um okay so I think I don't have
actually much
time to cover that so what does the
correct heavy estimator we made it as
weak weakest as possible for the sake of
the attack and it we could still attack
it so basically the requirement is
that every key that has a zero value
cannot be returned so basically the
estimator returns as a subset of the
keys and if the value is the value
squared is more than Epsilon fraction of
the L2 Norms it must be returned and the
rest we don't care and we still call it
correct and any estimator that kind of
takes a count sketch and returns and and
returns something like that and it can
be a different estimator each time but
we can still attack it with a attack it
meaning we can produce a bad input after
a number of queries that is the
quadratic in the sketch
size
um and basically this query Vector
attack vectors have a a very simple form
it's basically all have the same heavy
heator key and then say this joint
subsets that are basically just random
El we call
it um and the algorithm is basically the
only thing we you could use with these
estimators is basically you issue a
queries with different random TS and and
kind of the same heavy key but you draw
kind of the weight of the key from some
distribution um and then if the
algorithm tells you it's heavy H you add
you add this noise Vector positively and
then if it tells you it's not heavy you
subtract it and then after a quadratic
number of
queries um you get I think I'm almost
out of time time um uh you combine all
these TS with the signs and then it and
the idea is that the bias ER adds
up
um so a key that is reported heavy is
slightly more
likely ER to be biased in a certain way
like sorry a tail that is reported heavy
is slightly more likely to be biased in
a certain
way
um okay
time
okay
so um okay so this is a very general
form of attack it also works for the AMS
sketch also shows that after a quadratic
number of queries you can fail it no
matter what estimator you use any
estimator that under some value returns
zero over some value returns one you can
kind of use the same kind of attack
technique and find a bad
input
um so just for
fun we tried this attack on cifar it's
like
um ml data set of images um so so
basically we just added the
non-adaptively
random
noise and then based on this time we
kind of looked at the softmax results
and if the softmax was higher we added
it positively if it was lower the S Max
prediction for another class we added it
negatively and basically it was U pretty
effective in reducing uh the performance
uh with relatively small number of
queries so so basically my my the main
question here is like maybe a kind of
generalize this kind of a simple
ideas um
um so
that yeah it's like it works for count
sketch it works for AMS it works
empirically for a just a neural networks
that are not even completely linear in
the end but there are linear
layers kind of a show
generally what's going on understand
this
better
um so this attacks again the vectors are
simple natural almost not adaptive and
they kind of meet this uple bound
so
um
um and they can be applied to any the
attack format can be applied generally
so how far can we push it okay thank
[Applause]
you any more questions
fori I have a question s towards the
beginning you were talking about how we
care about adaptiv adaptivity not just
because there's an adversary but also
because we might be in a system with
feedback yes are there some examples
where you can design a
system uh with feedback where these
sketches break rather than as explicit
attack um so okay so um you can think
about natural
algorithms that kind of use the output
of the
following ER of the of the prior things
um I don't have a good example in this
case but kind of the attacks that we we
do use which is just like a um there is
a signal and then we add noise but the
noise could be also kind of maybe a
natural noise so you kind of observe
from the outside the outputs and and
because because the attacks that we kind
of used are n essentially nonadaptive
it's like you have a picture like a dog
and then you try it in all sorts of
noises so we we added actually random
noise but maybe even noise that is not
completely random but you just like look
at the biases the you just like look at
the responses so that maybe even that
alone can kind of allow you to H
construct a bad input I don't know but
it it doesn't show up in the algorithm
itself in an algorithm in some way but
at least you can get this information
just by observing a working system
enough information to kind of find
something that fails it right right
right
thanks
oh thank you um could you hope to have
attacks uh that are say insertion only
or deletion only and still work like say
you're only allowed to add things in
some if that question makes sense you
mean in a streaming
yeah
um okay so we kind
of um or you mean just a positive
updates
yeah
um yes so the noise that we added is
signed and that was kind of
critical yeah so and also
with positive updates things don't
change that much yeah so you don't er um
you know like if you look at like Norms
or Heavy Hitters it's like it's
logarithmic maybe number of changes so
it's not as much of an issue right yeah
so so maybe this is easier against such
an adversary yeah it's like David I
think can this better okay but he's he's
doing so that I don't know what he's
doing yeah so yeah so positive updates
and streaming basically it's like you
get very few changes in the output yeah
so
maybe yeah
thank
you so there's this gap between this
like exponential number of queries you
can do in the non-adaptive case and this
like D Squared you can do in the
Adaptive case right is there any hope
for like a sufficiently weak adversary
where you can hope to find some middle
ground or is just sort of like a
completely hopeless ideal in some sense
so
okay so it's like very problem specific
right okay um I mean some people looked
a all sort of weakening techniques for
adversaries right um but you know the
frustrating thing is that even for a
like for count sketch for AMS sketch
it's like can yeah okay it's this square
and with the regular yeah so yeah so our
intuition was that no that this cannot
be real but apparently it is um fair
enough yeah cool
thanks any last
questions thank Edith once again thank
you and so we'll meet back here and